[Musique]
bienvenue dans le making of c'est ça qui
fait que nous a contactés pour la santé
la série sex education nous ont dit la
laisser couler ce que voulait faire une
vidéo à ce propos et tournage louis
vient on regarde un épisode l'épisode
est
[Musique]
diva en rapport avec la série on va
parler de notre sexualité à nous une
anecdote sacré et qui a marqué notre
existence et on la libre devant des gens
devant nos potes devant des personnes
des élèves qu'on ne connaît pas et de
bord youtube
[Musique]
on essaie de trouver des équivalences
scientifique et morale non plus
acceptable que des mots vulgaires de qu
un exemple très synchro chatte on avait
des anecdotes chacun de cul de sac qui
sont parfois très gênante et on va
vouloir affronter l'idée de sous jacente
c'est de dire on en a tous ça va
sûrement vous arriver ça faisait déjà
pas arrivé et autant se libérer autant
tout dire ça sert à rien de garder c'est
pas grave ça arrive à tout le monde
tu n'écoutes pas ce que je dis je suis
pas
[Musique]
le but donc c'est l'anecdote le plus
possible de la loose je sais pas
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi oh dis
pas qu'on paie non si tu dit pas son nom
- de clément ah oui je vais rater
matériellement et très bientôt 20 h
john mica dedans humain
[Musique]
des élèves qu'on ne connaissait pas et
en fait ça met la pression
c'est dur tu vas demander jeune et tu
racontes d'être tellement intime j'ai eu
une vie sexuelle de merde ils ont été
très cool ferait sourire accroché motivé
sympa gros clubs français et mais
c'était groggy
tous ces moments impressionnants malaise
en a qu'on a dans la vie sexuelle je le
garde pour nous et tout pour se libère
on dit que ça arrive à tout le monde et
c'est pas grave mais on dit allez
bienveillance amour - c'est pas grave
d'être plus bas de 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]